[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace Norteamérica es un
gusto saludarlos desde Washington en
esta edición les contaremos Cómo Serán
las nuevas medidas migratorias que
implementará el gobierno de Joe biden
tras el fin del título 42 hablaremos con
analistas sobre los efectos que estas
decisiones pueden lograr para mitigar la
crisis migratoria también explicaremos
Cuáles han sido los efectos positivos de
la migración en Estados Unidos y
finalmente conversaremos con migrantes
para conocer cuáles son sus condiciones
de vida todavía creen en el sueño
americano
el 11 de mayo terminó la emergencia de
salud pública por el coronavirus en
Estados Unidos poniendo fin así el
título 42 la medida creada durante el
gobierno de Trump que permitió que se
expulsaran más de dos millones de
inmigrantes indocumentados esto
significa que ahora la patrulla
fronteriza no podrá expulsar a migrantes
con la excusa de salud pública a partir
de ahora opera el título 8 que permite
migrantes aplicar asilo en Estados
Unidos siguiendo las vías legales sin
embargo el nuevo paquete de regulaciones
entró en vigor y supone que los
extranjeros no son elegibles para asilo
en Estados Unidos si no aplican primero
asilo en un país transitorio además
tendrá que solicitar una visa a través
de una aplicación móvil para entrar al
país y solicitar otros permisos de
entrada a través de centros de
procesamiento que Irán pronto en
Colombia y Guatemala según Blas Núñez
neto subsecretario de política
migratoria y fronteriza esto ayudará a
mitigar la aula migratoria
para aquellos que no estén dispuestos a
esperar donde están y realmente usar
estos caminos legales es necesario que
haya consecuencias en nuestra frontera
terrestre hemos en los últimos dos años
realmente expandido nuestro uso de la
expulsión acelerada y también estamos
implementando en la frontera una nueva
reglamentación que creemos impone
algunas condiciones de sentido común
sobre la elegibilidad del asilo para las
personas que no aprovechan estas vías
legales que hemos expandido
para marduel Hernández miembro del
comité ejecutivo de la alianza nacional
TPS sea politizado al migrante Y no
habrá grandes cambios hasta que no se
aborda el problema de raíz
desastre naturales al clima el cambio
climático de pandemia conflictos
internos efecto de la corrupción
de esos son las raíces que se deben
atacar no estar criminalizando las
comunidades acá en la frontera la gente
viene huyendo y viene buscando una
oportunidad
el final del título cuarenta y dos es
una una jugada política nuevamente
Lamentablemente siguen jugando con
nuestra comunidad migrante utilizando la
agenda política de los que dirigen en
este caso este país lejos de ser una
carga económica para el país anualmente
los inmigrantes agregaron más de dos
millones de dólares al producto interno
bruto de los Estados Unidos desde el
2016 y pagaron 458 mil millones de
dólares a impuestos estatales locales y
federales solo en el 2018 esto según el
consejo americano de inmigración además
son La minoría que más crea empresas
beneficiando economías locales y
estatales pero la situación económica
para muchos migrantes que lograron
entrar a Estados Unidos antes del título
42 cada vez más complicada a esta
dificultad se le suman los peligros
derivados del racismo y la
discriminación muchos de los que ya
están aquí viviendo cuestionan El sueño
americano esta migrante venezolana llegó
a Estados Unidos hace ocho meses vive en
un albergue Y aunque trabajan no alcanza
para vivir dice que estaba mejor en
Colombia país donde vivió y ahorró el
dinero necesario para emprender el viaje
hacia Estados Unidos no no era lo que me
esperaba era totalmente diferente lo que
pasa es que a uno cuando viene en el
camino se basa en en cuanto comentario
por ejemplo muchas personas comentan
muchas cosas que mente que aquí es
diferente que aquí te dan esto te dan y
cuando tú llegas a la realidad
de diferentes posiciones políticas las
medidas que se adoptan en temas de
migración son pasajeras sirven solo para
aplazar la reforma migratoria que debe
aprobar el congreso para darle estatus a
los más deduce millones de inmigrantes
indocumentados en este país migrantes
que trabajan y contribuyen al desarrollo
económico de Estados Unidos a pesar de
que algunos políticos los perfilan como
amenaza económica y de seguridad y que
además los convierten en herramienta de
campaña
[Aplausos]
Muchas gracias por acompañarnos en esta
edición de enlace Norteamérica desde
Washington pueden enviarnos a nuestras
redes sociales comentarios y sugerencias
de temas que les gustaría que exploremos
en el programa os invito a seguir con la
programación de 24 en España Hasta
pronto